WHO DARES GET IN THEIR WAY.
A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER.
JOINING US NOW REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST ROGER STONE.
WELCOME BACK TO THE PROGRAM.
LET ME START WITH THE E-MAILS
THAT GO BACK HERE.
WORD IS -- THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
WORD IS A FRIEND IN THE
EMBASSY PLANS TWO MORE DUMPS.
CORSI WROTE ON AUGUST 2, 2016,
REFERRING TO JULIAN ASSANGE.
ONE SHORTLY BACK AND SECOND IN
OCTOBER IMPACT PLAN COULD BE
DAMAGING.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S SPECULATION
FROM JERRY CORSI WHO IS AN
EXCELLENT INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER.
NOWHERE DOES IT SAY JOHN
PODESTA'S E-MAILS HAVE BEEN
STOLEN AND WILL BE PUN LISHED.
JERRY SAID LAST NIGHT ON
"TUCKER CARLSON" THAT HE TOLD
ME AND OTHER PEOPLE THAT.
I HAVE NO MEMORY OF HIM
TELLING ME THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THE OTHER
PEOPLE MIGHT BE.
BUT IT'S DESPICABLE THEY PIT
JEROME CORSI AND I, BOTH
STRONG SUPPORTERS TO THE
PRESIDENT, AGAINST EACH OTHER
WHEN THE BOTTOM LINE IS
NEITHER ONE OF US RECEIVED
ANYTHING FROM JULIAN ASSANGE.
OR ANYONE ELSE.
>> Sean: YOU EVER TALK TO
HIM?
>> NO.
>> Sean: MEET HIM?
>> NO, NEVER.
NEVER MET HIM.
>> Sean: DID YOU GET TO
ASSANGE AT ECUADORIAN EMBASSY
IN LONDON, GET THE PENDING
WIKILEAKS E-MAILS OVER READ
THE E-MAIL, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA?
DID YOU SEND THAT CORSI?
>> YES, I DID.
BUT THERE IS SOME BACK STORY.
I HAD GOTTEN AN E-MAIL FROM
CHARLES ORTEL, A FORWARD FROM
JAMES ROSEN OF FOX, WHO HAD
SAID HE HAD A TIP THAT THE
COMING DISCLOSURES PERTAINED
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
THAT TURNED OUT, BY THE WAY,
TO BE FALSE.
I DID KNOW THAT JERRY'S
ASSOCIATE TED MALLOCK, NICE
FELLOW AND I KNEW IN NEW YORK,
MENTIONED THAT HE KNEW
ASSANGE.
I THINK IT MAY HAVE BEEN NAME
DROPPING.
I SAD JERRY TO GET IT.
JERRY DID NOT RESPOND AND DID
NOT SIND ME ANYTHING.
WE ARE TRAFFICKING IN
POLITICAL GOSSIP.
TRYING TO FIND OUT LIKE EVERY
POLITICO AND POLITICAL
REPORTER IN AMERICA WHAT IT
WAS THAT ASSANGE HAD.
BECAUSE HE HAD TEASED IT ON
CNN.
HE HAD TEASED IT ON FOX.
EVERY POLITICAL REPORTER IN
THE COUNTRY KNEW IT WAS
COMING.
WE WANTED TO KNOW WHAT IT WAS
ABOUT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS.
THE TWEET OF AUGUST 21, 2016.
"TRUST ME, IT WILL SOON BE THE
PODESTAS' TIME --" PODESTAS,
PLURAL.
LET ME TALK TO ANDY McCARTHY
AND GREGG JARRETT TONIGHT.
DID YOU EVER CONSPIRE TO HACK,
CON SPARE TO HACK, STEAL --
CONSPIRE TO HACK, STEAL ANY
E-MAILS FROM ANYBODY?
I SAY THIS IN THE PRECEDENTS
THAT DISCUSSED EARLIER, THE
"PENTAGON PAPERS."
>> NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ON JULY 31, THEY PUBLISHED
"FROM RUSSIA WITH MONEY."
AND IT WAS EXTENSIVE DEALING
WITH THE OLIGARCHS AROUND
PUTIN IN URANIUM, GAS,
BANKING.
AND JEROME CORSI HELPED
EDUCATE ME ABOUT THE FACT
"PANAMA PAPERS" IN APRIL OF
2016 DETAILED THE PODESTA
BROTHERS EXTENSIVE BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
BUT THE 21st WAS NOT EVEN
MY FIRST TWEET.
ON THE 15th, I TWEETED
THAT PAUL MANAFORT MAKES JOHN
PODESTA LOOK LIKE ST. THOMAS
AQUINOS.
SO THIS WAS NOT MY FIRST
TWEET.
SO THE CLAIM THAT I LATER,
THAT THE TWEET CAUSED
CONTROVERSY BROUGHT HEAT ON ME
WAS NOT TRUE BECAUSE UNTIL SIX
WEEKS LATER, WHEN ASSANGE DID
PUBLISH PODESTA E-MAILS THERE
WAS NO SOCIAL MEDIA
COMMENTARY, NO MEDIA
COMMENTARY.
THERE WAS NO CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION.
THERE WAS NO MUELLER
>> Sean: LET ME ASK THIS.
>> THERE WAS NO SUBPOENAS.
I HAD NO NEED FOR A COVER
STORY.
>> Sean: WITH I CONSTRUCT
AND THIS IS FROM JERRY CORSI.
I WILL ASK HIM IN A MINUTE.
WHAT I TESTIFIED TO THE GRAND
JURY I BELIEVE I WAS CREATING
A COVER STORY FOR ROGER
BECAUSE ROGER WANTED TO
EXPLAIN THE TWEET.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL KNEW THIS.
THEY CAN TELL MY KEY STROKES
ON THAT COMPUTER.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT?
>> MY POINT IS I HAD NO REASON
FOR A COVER STORY.
JERRY SAID I WAS GETTING HEAT
BUT THERE WAS NO HEAT.
FOR SIX WEEKS NOBODY NOTICED
THE TWEET.
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE PODESTA
PAPERS WERE FILED BY WIKILEAKS
THAT IT BECAME CONTROVERSIAL.
I HAD NO REASON TO COVER IT
UP.
I HAD NO ADVANCED KNOWLEDGE OF
THE HACKING -- PARDON ME, THE
THEFT OR THE PUBLICATION OF
THE PODESTA E-MAILS.
I HAD NO REASON FOR A COVER
STORY.
>> Sean: ROGER STONE, BY THE
WAY, THE BOOK "STONE'S RULES."
YOU THINK YOU WILL BE
ARRESTED, DON'T YOU?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
IF THIS IS DIDN'T ON THE BASIS
OF ACTUAL EVIDENCE AND THE LAW
AND THE FACTS, NO.
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING ILLEGAL.
I HAVE BEEN TARGETED FOR ONE
REASON AND ONE REASON ONLY.
I'M LOYAL TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
I STRONGLY SUPPORTED HIS
ELECTION.
I STARTED URGING HIM TO RUN IN
1988.
AGAIN IN 2000.
AGAIN IN 2012.
THAT IS WHY I'M TARGETED.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT GAVE
STATEMENTS TODAY LEAKED HE
ANSWERED TWO QUESTIONS.
ONE WAS ABOUT YOU.
DID YOU TALK TO THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT JULIAN ASSANGE OR
WIKILEAKS EVER?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Sean: SO THE PRESIDENT
TOLD THE TRUTH IN WHAT WE
LEARNED TODAY?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
AT NO TIME DID DONALD TRUMP
AND I, CANDIDATE TRUMP OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP DISCUSS
WIKILEAKS.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO DESTROY
YOU FINANCIALLY TO MAKE YOU
PLEAD GUILTY TO A MINOR CRIME
YOU DIDN'T COMMIT.
JUST LIKE GENERAL FLYNN.
I HAD TO SET UP
STONEDEFENSEFUND.com AND WHY
THEY ARE TRYING TO SENSOR ME
ON INFOWARS SO I HAVE NO
PLATFORM TO RESPOND TO THE
PERSONAL ATTACKS.
IT'S DEVASTATING WHEN THEY TRY
TO DESTROY YOU LIKE THIS.